alright guys so if you weren't busy
enough you thought why don't we start a
magazine the next step usually right you
know is interesting price we you know
feel we have this great connection with
our audience for the TV shows through
Drew's podcasters West's podcast we
thought this would be the perfect way to
really get those aspirational images in
front of people but also showcase
amazing designers we know amazing chefs
people who can really give you simple
steps to improve your life yeah exactly
it's it's a lifestyle magazine so
there's more than just home home is that
platform to a springboard for life and
so really excited travel food however
you want to be inspired in your life
this is to let you live the fullest life
it's just a fun read they're pretty but
also pretty boring like we want to do
something that is just fun and you'll
know it was an article about
organization in the home that's what
really gets you going
I was gonna ask you guys you're on the
cover here now we think of celebrities
who've starred magazines Oprah comes to
mind so now you're in the Oprah realm
yes we have not met her but she is an
inspiration and and absolutely
everything that she does in life her
whole life is about inspiring other
people to live their best life and
that's what we love and that's what we
try to do through our shows and through
reveal well you have some celebrity
notes in the magazine Kate Hudson's home
could we get ever something with Oprah
like this is this is the time why not I
mean we've all call you yeah we want to
be able to showcase you know people that
you see on TV every day or you see in
the news we want to showcase what
they're like at home what home means to
them so you'll see those stories there's
hilarious lifestyle fail stories as well
so we have the first issue has Zooey
Deschanel I may know her and you know
and so she you know she talks about how
she inadvertently got thrust into talent
competition when she was younger that
she didn't realize was a talent
competition and so we want to show the
fun side of life right down to when
you're renovating your house if you're
creating your dream home it should be
fun it should I had a great experience
and so you'll see these stories that
will show you how you can have fun with
it and it's also it's not just
celebrities that we're showcasing in the
magazine it's also everyday people too
and their stories I get emotional
but also we have one segment cassava is
our online marketplace it's our
inspiration platform for people in their
home and we actually are using cassava
and designers that everyone knows and
we're making over spaces so our readers
are submitting spaces in their home and
then we're giving them three looks in
the magazine with a digital makeover so
it's your room that you email in and
we're having three designers do three
finishes so there's a great reveal
moment as well that's the dream by the
way I think that all the time I watch
you guys is shown like I just wish there
was an easy way and I have given it to
the people you've given it what they
want so how do you find the time for it
all I'm really asking that I mean you
guys are in the realm of like the Ryan
Seacrest's or the those people who do so
many things that we look and we wonder
when do you sleep when do you workout
when you eat well and actually we were
literally just talking to Ryan about
that a couple of days ago it's for
someone like him to that's really really
busy you you thrive off of it you love
to stay busy you love to see a passion
of yours grow and I think we're exactly
the same well this perpetual motion
machine because we can naturally divide
and conquer doesn't feel like too much
when you love what you do you know it
helps you finish each other's sentences
you streamline conversations that saves
time I feel like it's just drew cuts me
off well I do yeah yeah okay now I also
have to ask you you're on the cover here
um Oprah is always on her covers will
you always be on the cover of reveal Oh
God Never Say Never you know maybe
there's something else for now we think
it's just a unique way that we can bring
our brand to then front and center a
natural progression for the magazine
we'll go from this to this to this and
then it will be called drew magazine I'm
out of here
is that that cover the right one I did
yeah but looking on the cover too one
thing we want to make sure is you know
with me hanging off of the V there one
thing that people know us for is you
know we're a family brand we love
helping people but we also like to have
fun so we wanted to make sure that the
cover represents that photo okay what
actually happened when we shot this
cover is the funniest thing in the world
secret oh yeah hold us up this so
originally drew was doing like this
muscle flex bent arm thing this is how
hey it looks so weird you just hang flat
like no doesn't he's like the rock
wouldn't hang off a helicopter like that
we're like you ain't the rock and this
isn't a helicopter it's the letter V so
just hang flat I don't
the bicep that he has to hang off of a
bee like that of all the comparisons for
you to make comparing your lifestyle
magazine to the rock no I've been told
that the rock can I could be twins you
know no don't you don't see it but look
at his glutes okay though I would point
out I believe the rock Dwayne would be
great at demolition so maybe he does
have a let me out actually this is a
this is a Cobra endanger this is a
partnership that we just figured out
needs to happen I also want to ask you
guys I mean look you you kind of did
that little pinup joke for us a minute
ago you guys are looking handsome by the
fire here will we ever go thirst trap
with any photos of you in the magazines
like the people might want to see you
shirtless garden oh I wasn't asking what
is thirst-trapping-- I've no idea what
that means um you know you never do
gardening shirtless yeah that's how all
rugged man you garden I do like to belt
Sam naked that's not something you want
to see no I mean that's not that would
be my nightmare I this is this is all
about inspiring people and through
design through food through adventure so
it really is a broad lifestyle magazine
it's not it this is not just you know I
mean our shows are about slow motion
right it's not a Harlequin romance novel
yeah but I do it is about wellness too
so have a healthy sign life mind body
and soul is a very important thing for
us to and so there will be a lot of that
focus in the magazine too okay is
everything so the magazine is called
reveal I want to play a little game with
you guys we're gonna get you to reveal a
few things you see we did there all
right for drew reveal one thing we don't
know about your marriage Linda and I are
little nerds and we have a shared note
on our iPhones and we try to every day
or every other day we add on to it so we
have this lifelong story over the years
since we've met and whether it's drawing
a little funny picture based on
something that we did that day for
example Linda was talking about the
Leaning Tower of Pisa but she loves
pizza so I had turned her into a leaning
tower of pizza and hey so little things
like that so we have this sort of long
love letter that is ongoing for the rest
of our lives
Wow okay I mean set the love bar very
high and then Jonathan
who made the first move with you and
Zoey we like to joke because so we met
on carpool karaoke right and so I was in
like I mean I was just playing it pretty
chill you know she was being super
friendly and a little flirty and she's
like what are you talking about you were
super first I'm like no no you were more
flirty the producers came back and they
said that I was flirting so bad that
they had to edit down the cut okay when
you watch carpool karaoke it's not out
yet but you'll see that you know looks
like she's a lark
apparently if you watch the full cut I
was in like yes it would be me I'm gonna
talk to them to get this full cut I
think that'll be hilarious to watch
unedited I'm so glad you guys had a
witness you had a third party to say no
no we're making the call by the way I
can tell when Jonathan's interested in
somebody but he thinks he's so cool and
casual not interested in Lynne and I
afterwards were like oh yeah he's
totally I was like no no guys we're just
all having fun oh I know
Quinn's no you smoother in my head than
I laughs I mean from having fun to she's
just a contributor in your magazine you
really cemented this all this was a ploy
to get her in the magazine will we see
Zoe the magazine more it was this kind
of a special thing for the premiership
you're gonna see a good eclectic mix of
our friends and other celebrities and
designers for the magazine so it's and
in our family too so mom and dad are in
the first issue you'll see I mean it's
it's a quarterly magazine so there's
four issues a year we got lots of time
to show a lot oh yeah it's a deeper dive
into our lives you know people our fans
were saying from our shows they'd like
to see more about us and our family and
more than just home and so you'll see a
lot more of that and then also digging
into family stories and lifestyle
stories with other people and what we're
talking more we're not talking more skin
so no more shirtless is that are we
going to shirtless now for this
interview
oh no okay who doesn't need any
encouragement look this is the last
phase of giving the people what they
want listen I'm gonna show you what the
rock did teach me this is the one thing
Dwayne did teach me oh man
that's it there you go the PEC pop those
either Terry Crews of the rocket can't
remember they're both able to have those
muscles
I don't physically even know where those
come from
I can I can jiggle if I do
splurt hey Zoey
it's not it works it's what do you think
it did right honestly we just we
literally laugh non-stop all the time
and so having that ability to you know
really entertain each other is great but
I've never been in a relationship where
I'm a romantic guy I like to do romantic
things I've never been in a relationship
where that is given back to me and so
it's really the perfect balance
oh we're over the moon Linda and I love
seeing him so happy we've actually
haven't seen this happy in years and
it's like he was saying - seeing someone
that's receptive and wants to do those
little extra things for him someone who
wants to spend time with the family and
I love Yorkshire pudding and let me tell
you so E has made me Yorkshire pudding
many times already so he's a good boy
made it again last night and I forgot to
bring in much yeah Magazine the recipes
got to go in there she even sang before
she even met our parents
she sang my dad's favorite song to him
over over FaceTime yeah Danny Boy mm-hmm
yeah so my dad my mom says to me after
she's like Zoey can literally never do
any wrong I mean this is sounding pretty
cemented okay I love her family I love
her like it's this it's a good match oh
my gosh I love hearing this okay we're
back to our game reveal one thing about
each other that the public does not yet
know Oh hmm something about Drew that
the public does not know I can talk to
Jonathan we'll have a whole conversation
and then realizing that he was
completely zoning me out the whole time
that's something people I know he sleeps
with his eyes open sometimes it's creepy
drew takes lessons for literally
everything anything because he doesn't
want to reinforce that habit so guitar
golf ping-pong dancing whatever it might
be
he'll take a lesson for absolutely
anything I like lessons I like my
philosophy is why reinforce bad habits
when you can learn to do it right
Wow you're sounding so different right
now it's like you're barely awake and
you're studying everything Annika you
guys are both in very happy
relationships but revealed your
celebrity Hall Pass do you have one
I don't your kind of or dating yours
maybe yeah no I mean it's not I mean
there there there I've always said Emily
Blunt is an amazing woman and she's
hilarious and been beautiful obviously
but a Hall Pass just she beats him she
seems like a cool person yeah that to
have game nights with did you guys have
the same first celebrity crush or did
you have different ones no I remember
way back in the day I had Tyra Banks
Tyra Banks yeah and Christina Applegate
oh yeah I remember I never had a poster
but we weren't allowed to have posters
on her wall just kids so I put the
poster behind like a cartoon there
yesterday that I had until when mom and
dad were around it could be like I don't
know why I know I made you cooler too
but I had um what's-her-name from
Baywatch yeah I don't I don't know I had
a Pamela Anderson poster when I was a
kid I don't understand why because I
never watched Baywatch either I don't
even know but I love doing slow-motion
runs in a red tight suit let's say that
peck thing for Pamela that's it Pamela
this is my she's got a restraining order
family maybe she'd give you lessons
amazing reveal the most romantic thing
you've ever done
oh well I'll reveal drew hired me to do
a romantic scavenger hunt for when he
first started dating Linda hired you I
didn't pay you I mean I made a website
and then it was a thing where Drew had
set up all these little like experiences
and prizes of things and he was busy
doing to him so he had me create this
whole scavenger hunt for him and I
wasn't busy it's just I have no idea how
to build a website and he did and I'm
like can you do this for me for me I
actually wrote a song for Linda this is
for the day of our wedding I wrote a
song for her I wouldn't record it in
studio and then I had it pressed to
vinyl because she loves records and she
loves old record players and so then I
have it delivered to her she was getting
ready with all the bridesmaids and this
is right before the ceremony and so she
played the record listened to me sing
this lovely song and her she ruined all
her made her make a brand name get
married yeah she loved you for that
most romantic and also biggest jerk moon
yeah yeah but have you and Zoey sang
together well we all we all sang
together doing carpool karaoke
oh yeah yeah exactly yeah so that that
was fun that was a lot of yeah we've
done karaoke we also at the holidays
we're singing Christmas carols yeah but
also when we did carpool karaoke like
her and Emily have voices of angels like
they have Emma Jonathan are like so we
think we can sing a little bit but
they're amazing so they kind of lifted
us up a little bit that was the most
dead-on like self-critical person Asian
all right reveal your guilty pleasure
guilty pleasure okay it brings
definitely escape phrase a lot escape
rooms but this is so weird for most
people but I just love coins like and
old coins I collect old coins and so as
soon as somebody mentioned something
about an old coin I have some from 2000
years ago and in 10th century England
and do you take lessons about how to
collect coins I don't take lessons but I
shouldn't take a lesson on how to read
if it's the right version of the client
way that's my guilt that is the nerdiest
guilty it is if you ever want to spark
up conversation with me hock old coins I
I came in I walked into Drew's room one
time we this is our coin collection as
kids which was pretty big we were into
it and then didn't touch it for like 30
years and then he picked it back up I
came into his room one day and I'm like
what are you doing and he had all the
coins and bills spread out on the bed he
was laying on the bed looking at them
looking at them just petting mooing no
it looks like you're rolling around
making love to claim you know it's
adding value I think that's the most
romantic thing you've ever it was
today's Cody did you see most romantic
to Linda or my coins yeah Wow very like
Scrooge McDuck moment Wow um well so do
you guys have any getting back to the
magazine Kate Hudson is Zooey Deschanel
any other celeb faces you can tease that
we're gonna see coming up soon or homes
we're gonna see from anybody we know
yeah I mean we can't use what's in the
future magazines but all of the
celebrities that we have in there are
you know the biggest names you can
possibly imagine and people who you
really would love to see inside their
home and they open us they open their
doors and they welcomed us with wide
open arms don't try to steal our
surprises for the set
issue all right well maybe you'll tell
me this who do you think's the most
famous person you each have in your
phone who could you really shoot a text
to you know I actually have a thing
where I have fake names for the people
who you know even though there's a
pastor over hold everything if for any
reason my contacts got out people
wouldn't know who the people are Donald
Duck is the most famous you'll have no
idea who that is
what if you forget who you mean what
that's what I think he's gonna hear I'm
banking on not being an idiot Wow okay
we're here at home so we got to bring
Linda and Linda yes get in here girl
hello by the way the most aesthetically
coordinated trio I mean you guys hit the
nail on the head every time this is a
traveling show now we dance so you guys
just had a ton of family in town for the
holidays 18 18 people in one dog 18
people in one dog and that's including
five kids under six they all stayed here
at the house with us and we were all in
Vegas for Christmas - so it's been busy
but it's fun I mean family is everything
this and you and Zoey were part of all
this - were you staying here there's
literally no room in this house but yeah
we spent as much time together as we
could over the holidays and it's that's
that's what I think my resolution last
year was moving in tonight 2019 2020
it's all about friends and family yeah
well I got a grill you a little bit now
that we have sister-in-law here because
look at these two got married a
beautiful wedding are you thinking like
are you and Zoey on that path because on
Instagram you posted once in a lifetime
you meet someone who changes everything
and that seems like a pretty big
beautiful statement it is I mean I I've
never been with somebody who gets along
as well with the people I care about
who
who shows me daily that she loves me and
I love her in return so it's I mean I I
love the fact that if you took me a year
ago I would never have thought I was on
this path with somebody who I'm madly in
love with so very exciting and you guys
love her yeah we get along really well
we're doing dinner last night so yeah
9:30 this morning is because of our
escape from and Joey took our whole
family for dinner I love to cos oh he
said to me that Linda's the sister she
never had and so yeah Emily no Emily she
wanted to have like you know something
she loves the fact that Linda's into
crafting and that Linda's as creative a
person so she's like I love that you
know I've got like this other sister no
she just wanted to have a sister shorter
than her I'm gonna do just said she gave
you the pants you're wearing yeah
there's something wrong you can't I
don't have feet right now you guys are
sharing clothes it's on that level
that's our clothes you guys are um well
it sounds like you two would really
welcome her as part of the family if you
guys do keep going and getting even more
so of course yeah of course and have you
ever thought about like if you were to
get married one day again is it is it on
the same level as these two nothing
could ever be in this their wedding was
the most beautiful amazing incredible
thing ever
in fact it must be a Scott family thing
because JD and Anneliese wedding was it
was a Halloween full costume wedding it
was the most incredible thing so it's
like the bar has been raised so high
my last question have you and so we
talked about that like it are you guys
in that place look maybe what's our
future what are we discussing
no we right now we're just reveling in
the fact that we love each other madly
and we're still discovering each other
it's the most incredible relationship
ever so we're contending that but it's
this is definitely you know something
that I've never experienced before in my
life and you guys are all gonna sing
together in carpool karaoke this is
gonna be what we need to see let's talk
about the podcast again you guys didn't
have enough going on see you soon let's
just really dig into podcasting
what are you
I want to accomplish with that what do
you want the fans to really get out of
listening to you for well for us firstly
I wanted us to sit down and relax and
actually talk to the people in our life
that yeah who inspire us yeah I mean a
big thing for us is because we have a
busy pace this is a nice way to slow us
down and I mean I feel we love sharing
stories with people and so just to be
able to do that as a part of our podcast
at home with Linda Andrew Scott it's
inviting inspiring people into our home
and and hearing their stories as well so
it we've been getting a lot of positive
response from people so go to at-home
podcast connect it's wherever podcasts
are available and you know what sounds
like a really great rating 5 I'll admit
to when we did our interview you guys
got stuff out of zone in me that I did
not anticipate you were gonna get out of
us so oh yeah very I love the mix of
people that we have sitting down and
chatting with us too from joy Cho from
the old joy brand how we mendel all of
our families so our older brother and
Anna Lee his wife mom and dad Jonathan
and Zoey so it's gonna be a lot of great
conversations and I hope you guys
enjoyed what did they get out of you
guys but you did very sneaky well you
know I do want to ask I mean obviously
Zoey has a has been in this industry for
a long time was there any hesitancy on
your part about dating another celebrity
or did you guys have discussions about
how you wanted to reveal your
relationship because you've been pretty
beautifully open with it I think with
your fans um well we've been really open
with each other
yeah everything there's no competition
in our relationship you know I went
supported her on her tour her Christmas
tour with her band you know she's come
and supported me on events that we were
doing as well it's just it's been just
such a natural fit easy yeah and it's
it's the same thing like we got so
caught up in laughing and singing and
you know all of the things that we love
doing together that we realized nothing
else matters the only time they're
competitive Scrabble Scrabble
these are big on game nights oh we love
it huge oh my god they shot us a look
like no I mean like no there's the
creepy thing I was thinking my head I
was like I'm gonna hang out with
like I can't say this but escape room
Scrabble singing hi man
okay my phone under a fake name gonna be
Donald Duck they were to put fake names
for people in their phones on the cool
is it was in the phone what's the
library's in there we'll see last
question for you guys you were talking a
little bit about like the setup of the
podcast I feel and it's on brain for you
you might have the most like
aesthetically perfect podcast setup that
there is how much did you think about
what you wanted the space to look like
well I mean because this is us inviting
people in our home and we're not talking
just home construction design with
people at home as a springboard for life
just like our magazine reveal and so we
wanted to use this as a platform what
home means to everyone that comes in and
we also didn't want where we're
recording to look like a studio yes it
literally is one of our living spaces
and it's just a nice comfortable casual
place to sit down and have these
conversations
[Music]